sal was recently meditating and asked
the universe
to send cardinals closer to him he
envisioned the cardinals standing right
on his window ledge
the next day it actually happened there
was a cardinal on his window
now that's unusual right a cardinal on a
window ledge
his house says his mission is not to
talk to animals but to validate the
importance of the universe what does
that mean
animals the land the sea the trees the
plants the people
were all one and um
these little signs are proof of it to me
you know yesterday i was outside okay
and i started
i started singing that song close to me
why
do birds suddenly appear and i
swear to you four red cardinals flew
over my head as i sang that and landed
on a tree in front of me
now you could say that's a coincidence
it's not a coincidence
it's the universe saying sal you believe
in us we're giving you these signs and
it's important
for me to share it you're too old for
this you're a grown-ass man
this nut is running around his
neighborhood
talking to everything inanimate well i
told you it's like
it's like a dopey snow white that's what
snow white used to do she was walking
around with those dwarves she's hanging
around there's birds flying over her
head she's singing
everybody he's living in a fantasy world
and it's
it's helped me develop so much more
respect for our universe and for people
listen to me this is nothing profound
going on in your head
everyone knows this is the universe to
say we're all
one is like they print that on [ __ ]
posters
you're not einstein i know but i'm no
longer taking your schmendrickstein
the worst thing is however he thinks the
universe is responding to him
yes that's the problem oh
this is great the cardinal that's been
talking to sal recently is on the phone
and wants to communicate with sal
uh i got to be honest with you i just
like [ __ ] with this guy i mean me and
the other birds all we do is we [ __ ] on
him we fly over him as he meditates it's
hilarious
i mean you're back he's an idiot right
he's so stupid i mean we got this racket
going on with the other squirrels we're
all in his backyard laughing at him
while he's meditating
joke i fly over there and it's just
endless entertainment every day
very long island uh bird
that's where he lives right hey i'm
filming a [ __ ] nest over here